the science of black holes is so
challenging that some scientists
question whether they exist at all
[Music]
despite their fearsome reputation
we've never actually seen one
black holes are everywhere they're all
over the universe they're all throughout
our galaxy but that doesn't mean that
they're easy to find
they're black and space is black and
black on black is kind of hard to see in
a picture of space
this is paradoxical because scientists
believe black holes are born in some of
the brightest explosions in the universe
rising from the corpses of detonated
Stars many times larger than our sun
a star that burns for 10 million years
collapses to form a black hole in a
period of seconds
as it collapses the outer region of the
star hits the core triggering a huge
explosion a supernova
[Music]
we see the bang but not what's left
behind
dead core with the enormous mass of the
star crushed down into an infinitesimal
tiny area
[Music]
from this minuscule high mass core
a black hole is born
the flow of gravity is so strong that
nothing can escape not even light
[Music]
but how can scientists claim that black
holes exist if we can't even see them
[Music]
you could say that about the existence
of the atom we knew they had existed for
decades centuries before we had actually
seen one in some sort of Imaging device
and so it's the same sort of thing with
black holes
just because you can't see it doesn't
mean it's not
it's not no that wind is there even
though we can't see air
[Music]
is invisible
the Wind Blows Its effects can be
measured
it's the same with black holes you just
need to know what to look for
while they emit no light themselves
black holes are tremendous sources of
X-rays and that's because as things get
close to a black hole they're
accelerated by the gravity and they can
heat up to millions of degrees
million degree gas gives you lots of
x-rays
[Music]
to find and measure these Telltale
x-rays
scientists turn to the new Star Space
Telescope
in 2017 it spots a burst of x-rays in a
cluster called 47 tucana at the edge of
the Milky Way
when scientists analyze the data they
realize they're looking at two objects
orbiting each other very closely
[Music]
all we see is that there's a star being
ripped apart and gas is spiraling down
to a very dense very dark object so
something weird is going on
as one of the objects accrets matter off
the other it causes it to emit X-rays
and those x-rays can be used then to
trace out the orbits and therefore
extract the mass
[Music]
when scientists work out the size and
mass of the two objects they find the
first is the fading corpse of a sun-like
star
and while the second object is Tiny it
has the mass of a giant
is this an elusive black hole
what we're talking about here is an
object that is very massive very small
very dense with intense gravity
but it turns out there are lots of
different ways to create an object like
that
there is another type of ultra dense
object out there in the universe called
a neutron star
neutron stars form in the same way we
think black holes form when stars die
explode but then collapse down into a
tiny ball of matter
the gravitational attraction of a
neutron star is enormous pulling in gas
dust and asteroids but light can still
Escape
black holes and neutron stars are kind
of cousins but in the case of a neutron
star it didn't have quite enough Mass to
collapse out of control so you can sort
of think of it as just barely hanging
back from collapsing into a black hole
tiny object discovered by NuStar does
have enormous Mass
but size and mass alone are not enough
to prove it's a black hole
cosmologists need more evidence
they can't see black holes
is there another way
what if they could hear them
think of two massive cars colliding boom
when they do they radiate sound and then
we can tell whether or not that
Collision occurred and maybe even how
far away it was it's like that when
black holes collide
[Music]
so by listening for a black hole crash
could scientists conclusively prove they
exist
[Music]
there are gravitational waves going
through this room all the time every
time I move my hands like I just did I
create gravitational waves the problem
is gravity is so weak
that you don't detect those
gravitational waves
in order to detect those disturbances of
space and time you have to have
cataclysmic events involving massive
objects
[Music]
black holes are some of the densest
objects in the universe
so we should be able to hear and measure
the waves created when they collide
ligo the long interferometry
gravitational wave Observatory listens
for waves that can come from over a
billion light years away
in 2017 ligo heard an enormous crash
[Music]
two very massive objects collided at
near the speed of light and one of the
most energetic events that we've ever
witnessed in the history of humankind
Two ultra heavy ultra dense objects
whirl around each other hurling powerful
gravitational waves through space
the closer they fall toward each other
the more gravitational energy they throw
out
finally they Collide in one of the most
violent events in the universe
the smash sends out immense
gravitational waves that Ripple across
Intergalactic space
[Music]
until eventually ligo detects them
[Music]
listening to a gravitational wave is
like listening to a musical instrument
if it's making certain tones or certain
vibrations you can figure out the size
of the musical instrument the type of
the musical instrument who's playing the
musical instrument
[Music]